Hi everyone and welcome to
our toxic Google event. Oh,
I'm going to go through
some logistics first.
This is a fire side chat style talks.
So it will take about 40 minutes
to talk through some questions.
And then in the last 20 minutes we'll
open up to the audience to submit
questions.
Um,
both in person here through a Mike in
the back of the room and also through the
dory at go slash ask Dash Sam.
And I'd like to thank everyone who has
helped out to make this talk possible,
including our facilities team and everyone
on the PM Speaker series organizing
team.
So it's great to have Sam Altman
here with us today for toxic Google.
Sam is the president of y Combinator,
which is widely regarded as one of the
top startup incubators in silicon valley.
He went to Stanford and studied computer
science and was the founder and CEO of,
uh, uh, mobile location
based startup called looped,
which was funded by Yc as part of its
first class of startups in 2005 and
acquired by Financial Services Company
green.in 2012 in 2014 he was named
president of y Combinator.
And since then he's worked on a wide
range of initiatives from YC research,
which is a nonprofit branch
of y Combinator that focuses
on doing pure research
around moonshot ideas like
universal basic income.
And he's also worked on open Ai,
which is a nonprofit AI research company.
Looking into finding ways to create safe,
friendly,
artificial intelligence that can
actually help all of humanity.
And it's great to have you here. Thanks
for having me. So just as I mentioned,
you're involved in a wide range of
things from YC to open the eye and most
recently you released the United slate.
So I wanted to ask you how you think
about prioritizing the projects that you
work on.
Yeah,
I think optimal time allocation is,
it's probably like an AI complete problem.
Um,
I think if you can get to spending
like 1% of your time perfectly, that's,
that's really good.
Uh,
and so I think this idea of figuring out
what to focus on and what not to focus
on is both really hard.
Uh,
and sill significantly under invested in,
um,
the frameworks that I have used.
The sort of two big frameworks that I've
used to figure out how to allocate time,
um,
one is impact maximisation
slash regret minimization.
Um,
so I try to look at those two curves
together and I try to think about where I
can have the biggest impact on the world.
Um,
net positive impact on the world,
uh, easy to have, big impact. Um,
and uh, and then also just regret
minimization. You know, you get,
you get to live once.
It's really that you do what you want
to do and that you spend time with the
people you'd like to work with and work
on the things that you find personally
if a filling.
And so if I think I'm going to really
regret doing something or regret not doing
something,
uh,
even if I think it's not the best use
of my time for a pure sort of in the
impact on the world, um, I'm
still willing to be like,
to take that really seriously.
And I think that makes me do
better at the things I do that,
that do help the world. Uh, so, you know,
the broad things that I've learned that
I like to do, um, one is teach people.
Um, another is create economic growth. Uh,
I really do believe that one of the
things that is most fundamentally going
wrong right now in the country is that
we don't have enough economic growth and
little that we do is not
evenly distributed at all. Uh,
and so I think in a democracy,
um, you, you really want,
everyone's lives to get better every year.
We're basically insensitive
to the absolute quality of
their lives and extremely
sensitive to relative differences year
over year to our neighbors. And it's,
it's really important that everyone's
life is getting better constantly. Um,
and I think economic growth supporting
to do that, I think that, um,
I think the AI is going to be the most
important technological trend of our
lifetime. So I'm spending a
lot of my time on that. Um,
and you know, I try to think about
things on those two strategies. Uh,
the other framework besides the sort of
impact maximisation regret minimization
that I found really useful is spend
a little bit of effort, China,
a lot of things and then relentlessly
prune down and focus quickly on the ones
that you like and the ones that seemed
to be working. So in some sense,
this is the y Combinator model,
um,
of fund a lot of startups with a little
bit of money. Um, and then, you know,
most don't work out in some work really
well and you spend more time and more
money on the ones that do.
And this is the, uh, hey guys,
this is the thing that I've tried
to apply to my life more generally,
uh, is this idea that I can try a lot
of things with a little bit of effort.
It's very hard to predict exactly what's
going to work and what hasn't. Um,
but then the hard part about that and the
thing that most people don't do is you
really want to relentlessly focus
down on, on the ones that do work. Um,
and the last thing I'll say
about prioritization is,
the other hack I have learned is if you
can get one really great partner with
you on every project,
that will cover up a lot of the slack
because if you try to do multiple things
at once,
crises come at the same times.
And that's really hard if you
have to do it all yourself.
And focusing more
specifically on productivity,
like what are some life hacks that maybe
you apply to make your everyday day
more productive?
Um,
and I think there's like a lot of crap
written about productivity secrets on the
Internet and people sort of like get into
this thing where they spend more time
like trying to be productive about
their productivity system and actually
getting things done. Um,
I will say I think that,
well, I'll say too, I think pieces of
advice that aren't the obvious. Um,
one is I think far more important than
any particular system is just figuring
out the right things to work on.
And so all of the time that people spend
with like this new productivity app or
that or whatever would be better spent.
Like really trying to
think diligently about,
I have the same number
of hours as anybody else.
What am I going to spend them on?
And getting that right is more important
than exactly like being perfectly
productive with those hours.
Um,
that'd be part of that is not
doing things that waste time. Uh,
I think if you can just like focus on
the things that are important and not do
the things that wastes time,
um,
you can be fairly sloppy
with productivity otherwise,
and you'll still get far more
done than most people. Um, it's,
it's really hard to do that.
The other thing that I think people
don't think about enough is figuring out
your own personal,
like rhythms of productivity.
And there's huge variance I've noticed
between people that figure this out and
don't. Um, so like for me personally,
it turns out that I am most
productive if I go to sleep late,
wake up late,
and then keep the first like three or
four hours of the day and don't schedule
any meetings,
like work from home,
like get through my list of stuff then
and then like pack all my meetings when
I'm kind of less productive.
It just grinding and stuff out or
thinking creatively in the afternoon. Um,
and like it took me some number of years
to figure that out cause it didn't like
fit well with the work schedule I was
naturally in. But then I was like,
all right, if this is like the thing
to that makes me most productive,
then I'm gonna like make my whole
schedule work to support that.
And that was like a really
important change for me. Um,
so I think figuring out your own personal
like optimal times to work on what
kind of different things, uh, people
don't really talk about that much.
And at least for me it had a huge impact.
Shifting gears a little bit,
but still trying to get your
perspective on different things. Uh,
related to day to day,
one of the key issues that has come up
recently is bias in the workplace and
both conscious and unconscious bias.
And I want it to get your perspective
on what are some of the strategies that
you implement personally,
whether in the way you interact with
people that you encounter or in how you
approach the decision making process in
using strategies to minimize your own
bias.
Look,
I think this is an important conversation
happening in silicon valley right now
and there's a lot of
opinions on a lot of sides,
but I would like to say
the following. I think, um,
no matter what you believe about biology,
no one that I respect does not believe
that women and racial minorities and a
number of other groups face an
absolutely unfair playing field. Um,
their entire lives.
I think people start getting told directly
and indirectly from a very young age,
um, this is the kind of thing you
should do or can do or whatever.
And that has an effect,
a company if I can anyone.
And I think trying to counter
that is really important.
And I think um,
again I think there are things people
can reasonable warming and people can
disagree on.
I think unfortunately we spend all our
time talking about the disagreements and
we don't focus enough on the agreements.
And I think almost all smart,
reasonable people will agree that the
society we grew up in has a hugely unfair
paint Plainfield.
Um,
and I think because of that it is not
enough to talk about unconscious bias.
I think that is a real problem.
To be clear.
I think we are all a product
of the society we are up
in and we all have biases
that aren't our fault but still a
responsibility to counteract. Um,
but one thing I don't like about the
discussion in Silicon Valley about
unconscious bias and how
that's the problem that we
need to fix is I think it is
not nearly sufficient and it
ignores the good thing to fix,
but it ignores the fact that,
you know,
decades or centuries of society have
built up a very uneven playing field.
Um, and that is why we
do need programs, um,
to try to proactively kind of that.
So, um, I think it's, you know,
I think it's really important we not
lose sight of that and that unconscious
bias training alone, although currently
very fashionable, will not fix that.
That said, I do believe
unconscious bias is a problem.
We try to counteract it a by talking
about it and doing training in which I
think does help. Um, but B,
I think one of the things that we have
done that unfortunately other investors
have not done as much is just have
a very diverse, um, partnership.
And we have, um, six
female gps on our team. Um,
and, and that's probably
a large part of the, um,
women in top of the best minerals
in silicon valley. Uh, and that's,
that's really that we have, um, you know,
the CEO of our core program is black. Um,
and I think,
I hate to play the kind of like who's
the most discriminated stack game,
but I think black entrepreneurs in
silicon valley have an exceptionally hard
time. Um, and I think by
having a more diverse team,
it helps us have broader networks and
also think about our own unconscious bias
all the time
and the issue of politics or maybe
even bringing these issues up in the
workplace to some,
sometimes seen as a taboo.
And yet you've been pretty vocal about
your views on current political events
and also other issues that are
coming up in silicon valley.
So I wanted to ask you how you walk
that fine line between expressing your
opinions,
but also minimizing any repercussions
that that could have on the day to day
business of Yc.
Well, now it's not even
controversial. Um, you know,
like now all the tech CEOS are
talking about politics. Um,
when, when I started doing it,
um, a couple of years ago, uh,
kind of at the beginning of the rise of
Trump, it was controversial. Um, two,
two things were going on.
One is I think no one took him seriously.
Um,
so most people rolling out of this is a
ridiculous thing that's going to go away
too, is that, uh,
I think in normal times it does make
sense for business leaders of large
organizations to remain
apolitical. Um, you know,
I think it actually does make that
makes a lot of sense. Uh, it's,
it's a huge distraction.
It's hugely time consuming and it has
all of these like weird negative effects.
Like, you know, if you piss
off the president, he can do
bad, bad things to you. Um,
however, however, these
are not normal times. Uh,
and I think the,
you know,
like when the future of the
republic is at risk, um,
the duty to the country and our values
transcends the duty to your particular
company and your stock price.
Uh,
and I think I started that a little
bit earlier than other people,
but at this point I'm in very good
company and it doesn't seem to be that
controversial anymore.
What are some things that you wish people
knew about you that they don't know
about you? Uh, you know,
at this point I would just like to have
like my own little quiet private life
back. I don't feel like, um,
I'll say nothing at all. Okay,
fair answer.
Moving on to talking a
little bit about why,
see and what you look for in companies.
Are there any qualities in founders that
you think are overrated or underrated?
Yeah,
I think the most underrated quality,
the most underrated quality of all
is being really determined. Um,
this is more important than being smart.
This is more important
than having a network.
This is more important than a great idea.
Um,
the hardest thing about
starting a company is
the level and the frequency of
bad stuff that happens to you.
And most people that are good and really
other ways eventually just get killed.
The company gets killed
by, um, stuff going wrong.
And you know so much about being a
successful entrepreneur is just not giving
up. Um, when we have funded
people who have a great idea,
perfect background on
paper and, um, you know,
a great product and still failed,
uh,
it has usually been that they're
insufficiently determined.
So I think this is the most important
non obvious skill of a founder. Um,
of course you need a good product
and a good market and to be smart,
but that's really obvious. Um, the
degree to which being like a, you know,
three or four standard deviation outlier
on determination is a required skill of
a CEO is not something that was
obvious to me when I started.
Uh, that's also bad because
it's really hard to select.
It's really hard to identify that,
you know,
as we have said more publicly
how important that is.
People applying to Yc,
I've gotten better and better at telling
us stories from their past life about
how they overcame these impossible
odds to get through something. Um, and,
and unlike intelligence,
which is very difficult to fake
in a, you know, one hour meeting,
you can definitely fake determination.
In a one hour meeting. Um,
so that's one thing that really matters.
Um,
another thing that really matters that is
non obvious, uh, is independent thought.
And,
and this I think as an even more
unusual skill then determination.
Um, I think both of these you can
make a conscious effort and build up,
but I think independent thought
is one of the hardest skills to,
um,
to,
to build up because like we are all
speaking of social pressures from birth,
we are all pushed to think
like other people. Uh,
and if you think in your own lives about
the number of people you spend time
with that you would say are
true independent thinkers
that consistently have new
ideas you haven't heard from other people
and think about the world in different
ways. Um, it's probably a very short list.
And yet these are the people that start
all the interesting companies that
consensus ideas. Everyone tries.
Google will eat your lunch at. Um,
and they're also not kind of the,
the really big trends of the future.
You want startup ideas.
If you picture a Venn diagram
and here you have, um,
is a good idea and here you
have sounds like a bad idea. Um,
you want that tiny little overlap and,
and those are the kinds of ideas that
are the hardest to identify and the ones
that, um, even if you do manage to notice
them, most people will talk you out of.
So I'd say those are two non
obvious skills that we look for.
And what's one challenge that YC companies
face repeatedly that you've noticed?
Um, hiring engineers, uh,
when Google can just sort of
like throw unlimited cash.
Anyone they want has become very
problematic for startups. Um,
I think the good thing about
that, I always try to, like,
I always try to find the
good in any bad situation.
And the good thing about this is it means
that if a startup does not all of the
startup, all of the really good startups
have really important missions. Um,
eventually they figure it out.
They may not have an on day one,
but they eventually get to
this like missionary mindset.
And it used to be that even
if you didn't have that,
like you could just sort of get a bunch
of mercenaries to come work for you and
now you can't because you
cannot be Google. And so, um,
one positive side effect of this
thing has been that startup,
the importance now of a startup having
a really clear and really important
mission on day three has gone up a lot.
And I think that's what you need it
better startups because otherwise you just
can't recruit. Um, uh,
another common problem that startups have,
and this doesn't sound
like a great insight, ah,
but most startups still don't ever
build a product that people want.
And it doesn't seem to matter
how much we talk about this.
It doesn't seem to matter how
much anyone talks about this.
People still keep trying
to do anything about this.
And if there's like one thing
that a startup has to get right,
it's built a product that people
really want, not a little,
if they want it a little bit, that kind
of, you won't generate enough momentum.
Like you got to build something
that some people really love and,
um, after failing because of
insufficiently determine founders,
this is the number two reason
that startups that seem
really good otherwise fail.
Okay.
Moving on to talking about
different technologies,
what would you say is the
biggest challenge that we're
facing in terms of making
progress on artificial
intelligence right now?
Well, I don't know if any
of you saw this, but, um,
open AI beat the best one being the
best single player Dota players in the
world. Um, last Friday and I,
when we started that project
at the beginning of this year,
I did not think that was gonna happen
this year and I wasn't even sure it was
going to happen next year.
Um,
and it was very wild to watch that
happen because it was almost purely self
training. Um, and it was this
very complex environment. Um,
and the AI was just playing itself and
getting better and better and better. Um,
in fact, the final Bot that we had
that beat all the humans handily,
um,
one day later it lost 60,
42 oh one day more of
all version of itself,
just to give you a sense for the
rate of improvement. Um, and,
and so I think people are kind
of asleep at the wheel here. Um,
there are problems,
but again,
in that same spirit of always trying to
figure out like the good, not the bad, um,
we are making unbelievable progress.
Maybe too much progress. Um, but I think,
I think of all the things
I worry about with Ai,
the technical barriers to progress
or not the top of the list,
there's another camp that says that maybe
we're placing too much emphasis on the
threat of Ai. Uh, what
do you think about that?
Yeah, I think we, we don't
talk enough about the benefits.
Um,
I think the AI has the potential to
eliminate like nearly all human suffering
and the next couple of decades.
I think we can have a world of abundance.
We can eliminate poverty over time. We
can probably cure a whole lot of diseases.
Um, bear all these wonderful
things that technology can do. A,
and I think we're already seeing that and
just how much better a lot of consumer
products we use every day had gotten.
Um,
people like disaster porn.
People are more interested in talking
about the end of the world than they are
about life getting 10% better every
year and having that component,
which gets a lot better. Um, so you know,
you can,
if you're a journalist,
you can write an article about how AI is
going to end the world and get a lot of
clicks and you know,
a page of your bonus or whatever you got.
Or you can like write an article about
how AI is like gradually making all these
problems 10% better. And probably no one
reads it. Certainly no one shares it.
And so I think
for whatever reason,
the way we'll wire it is to talk much
more about the downside of this than the
upside. But the upside I think is
going to be huge. It already is huge.
And what do you think about
cryptocurrencies? Do you see, um,
same growth? Uh, yeah. I
mean, I think, you know,
it's going to go up and down.
I'm like,
I bought my bitcoin a long time ago. I
plan to hold them for a really long time.
I try not to watch the price text,
but it's so addicting that I
can't help myself. Um, I think
this is not investment
advice. Um, I think,
I think the only super compelling use
proven use case we have seen so far is
store value and as a replacement for gold,
I think we are seeing real adoption
there and real collective belief that
actually makes it have some
value. Um, however, if that's
how it's gonna play out,
then I think, um, bitcoin should dominate
biggest network, first biggest brands,
most collective belief, whatever. Uh,
and so I have been surprised
by the continual strength
and all of the alt coins.
Um,
I think there are potential other truly
valuable applications of the blockchain.
Um, you know, file coin has a YC thing,
so I know that one pretty well
and I can see that being big,
but I think most of what's going on
feels like a complete outside of bitcoin.
It feels like a complete speculative
bubble and I feel bad that a lot of people
are going to get burned.
So I think probably the right thing
to do if you believe in it, um,
is to, you know, buy bitcoin and then I'll
think about it for another five years.
Is there any specific product area or
technology that you think people are
sleeping on?
MMM,
sure a lot. Um, AI as we mentioned,
I think people are asleep at the
wheel on a really big way on um,
nuclear fusion I think is within some
single digit number of years of working.
Uh,
and because it's been so bad for so long,
um, people are just kind of burned out
and not really taking a new look at new
materials and stronger magnets and better
computer models that's going to enable
this to work. Um,
synthetic biology, again,
it's like people talked about
it a lot a couple of years ago.
It didn't quite work as
fast as people are hoping.
So we have like this hype cycle
and then it really falls off.
And now we're in the part where I think
the interesting work is happening and
people aren't paying enough attention.
Um,
I guess that's a topic. Hang on for a long
time, but I'll limit it to three. Sure.
Is there any particular problem that
you think technology can't solve?
How to make us nice to each other?
Uh,
technology has clearly been quite bad
at solving. Um, I won't say can't.
Um,
but I haven't seen it yet and I certainly
don't think technology can by itself.
Um,
and I think the,
I think we are kind of in this situation,
um,
at least in the developed world where the
world keeps getting better and we keep
getting unhappier. And you know, there's
like a decent amount of data on this.
And I think,
um,
I think technology is not entirely to
blame, but it's certainly not blameless.
And, um, I think it's 30 minutes left.
I couldn't even start the conversation,
but I think the number of like things
that technology has done to make us,
um, more isolated, um,
feeling relatively worse.
I have a friend of mine,
um,
liberal,
older said she never used to be unhappy
because she had no idea what she was
missing. And now that she has to watch,
like I'm very bad at pop culture,
I'm going to pick a name,
a random Kim Kardashians,
like fly around in private
jets and Instagram all day.
She's jealous and it like makes her very
unhappy and it didn't use to happen.
Um, and I'm in the thinking about that
a lot in the last couple of weeks and I,
I don't have a solution to that,
but I understand why that's a problem.
So I think,
um,
figuring out how to make us like happier
and nicer to each other in particular.
I think one thing that technology
does, it's really bad is, you know,
we have some probably
longstanding evolutionary
pressure that even if I really
don't like you, I'm very unlikely
to come stand next to you and say,
I fucking hate you. You're
a jerk. Like, you know,
whatever else people say on Twitter.
A lot of things because there's this like,
you know,
we're like these pack animals and we have
to like live with each other and help
each other survive. Um, but somehow
like on Twitter, that goes away.
And, um, and I think like I'll
say my whole rant about Twitter,
but I think like that is a platform in
particular that rewards saying the most
aggressive,
snarky things.
That's how you get likes and retweets
and sort of value out of the platform.
But a lot of technology does this,
it,
we don't have whatever kind of like the
human be nice to each other in person.
Instinct is, and we have these
platforms that reward being bad,
reward being a jerk.
Uh, and, and so I think,
I'm not optimistic that technology
is going to solve that problem.
I think that's going to have to
be people saw me not a problem.
In an interview with Vanity Fair in 2015
you mentioned that you were optimistic
about the future and that was right
before all of the election stuff happened
and the situation that
we find ourselves in.
So would you say that you're
still optimistic about the future?
Um, like progress is not,
it's, it's not a perfectly
exponential curve. It's not,
it's not even a straight
line. Um, and you know,
we are clearly in a
challenging period now, um, but
I think if you look back at the last few
hundred and then a few thousand years,
um,
if you zoom out enough that the
squiggles on the curve kind of disappear,
um,
the world's getting so much better and
I think that's going to keep happening.
Um, and I am, you know, even with
everything going on right now,
um, I'm delighted to be alive right now
and not a hundred years ago and certainly
not, you know, 202,000 years ago. Um,
and I think we do have technology to
thank for a lot and we have better
governance. That's like the number
of people living in a democracy. Uh,
you know,
200 years ago was very low.
The percentage and as
horrible as things are,
the fact that we get to stand up and
speak our minds without fear of, you know,
being thrown in jail for
political opposition and
the fact that we get to vote
again three and a half more years.
Um,
I think that's amazing and I think it's
easy to take that for granted. But, uh,
yeah, I think the future is going to be
a lot better. I remain very optimistic.
What do you see as being a big challenge
that we're facing as a society right
now?
Uh,
how we deal with a world where the natural
forces are for wealth to concentrate
into the hands of a smaller and smaller
number of people. As I mentioned earlier,
um, I think people are more sensitive
to relative quality of life,
of an absolute quality of life. And I
think technology is naturally a force.
It's a giant lever that tends
to create way more wealth, um,
but really concentrated.
So I think one of the most
tone deaf things people say
in Silicon Valley is, um,
you know,
like poor people should be happy.
They get this android
phone for not much money,
they can access anything in the world. Um,
and they wouldn't have that without us.
So why are they complaining and, okay.
Like there is some truth to that.
I do think it is cool about the world
that like the richest person and someone
living in absolute poverty, um,
Carrie, you're on the same phone.
That that is something that would not,
there was no analogy to that other
than maybe like if you got a really bad
disease, there was no like a quality
like that, you know, 400, 500 years ago.
Um, however that point, which is always
what silicon valley falls back to,
I think it's like maybe
not the most possible, most
tone deaf possible response.
Um, but up there like people want
to feel like they have agency,
they want to feel like they
have a voice in the future.
They want to feel like
they can participate. Um,
and they want to feel like they're not
just kind of like given this baseline
while,
you know,
like they toil in the
provinces and silicon valley
just gets all the money. Um,
and I think people who don't see that
are just not thinking clearly. Um,
and so I think one of
the greatest threats,
something else I don't think technology
can fix on its own is how we get to a
more just world. I really, really
fundamentally believe that, um,
economic justice is the most important
thing you can do for social justice.
And if you have all of the resources
going to a small set of people, um,
even if everybody else has having their
absolute quality of life raise very
quickly,
that's not enough.
You recently announced a United slate,
which puts forth some policy proposals
as well as an invitation for candidates.
What would you say success
looks at like for that?
You know, if we can run five,
six candidates in the 2018 cycle,
um,
on that election,
on that platform and have two
of them when their elections,
um, I think that'd be an
incredible start. And you know,
maybe it doesn't work at all because
maybe the kind of maybe those issues,
although I believe they're important,
are not yet ready for,
to convince the public at large. Um,
but I think it will be a good start.
And I think over time it would be really
good if people on the progressive side
built up a kind of longterm organization
focusing on winning elections and
shifting public perception at all levels.
Um,
the right has done a fabulous job at this.
Congratulations to any of you who are
on that side, but I would like, uh,
the, the left to do a
better job at that. I don't,
I don't think we're putting
forward our best game there.
In your invitation,
you also mentioned that you'd be willing
to work with Democrats, independents,
and Republicans.
Is there any issue in particular that
you see anyone regardless of political
ideology coming together and agreeing
on more so than other issues?
Um, I think there are, there
are a lot of issues. Again,
I think people agree on way more than they
disagree on. So I think, uh, you know,
it's, we want around the state and talk to
Californians. Um, Republicans, Democrats,
San Francisco, La, Fresno, Shasta
County, wherever you go. Um,
the price of housing is like the biggest
issue for most sort of regular people
that are not Google employees. Um,
maybe even for Google employees. Um,
it's really, really bad. I mean this
is like, this is, if you could fix,
I think one thing that would have
hugely positive secondary effects.
Um, it's like bring the cost of
housing down by a factor of 10 would be
transformative for society.
It's
what eliminate government, right?
Eliminate government regulations. Yeah.
Like I think many regulations
have good elements. I'm not,
I'm not kind of the libertarian and our
kissed all government regulations are
bad, but I do think the, the
sort of no more building,
no building taller has been
disastrous for the state. Uh,
and I think like it is the worst possible
allocation of resources to have people
tie up every free penny they can find
into the place they live. I'm like,
think about anything else
we could spend that on.
I think about what it would be like if
people could like live close to where
they work rather than commuting an hour
and a half to get here each day. Um,
and that is something that
Democrats, Republicans, independents,
almost everybody agrees on a,
or at least there are people in all
of those camps that that do. Um,
so I think like, again, easy to talk
about the divisions, it's really good.
Then when you go talk to regular people,
um,
they all agree on what the most important
issues and they don't want to fix it
in the state.
What do you think the tech industry's
role is in government and politics?
Um,
look,
I think we are all citizens of
this country and we all have like,
you know, there is a, there is
a right to participate in the
electoral process. And I
think there's also not, is a
duty to do that. And I think,
uh, when I think,
I think tech is going through such a
boom right now, it is easy to say, Hey,
I'm just going to focus on like doing my
thing. Um, you know, building products,
making money, whatever, and I'm
going to figure out someone else's,
let someone else take care of the rest.
Um,
one of the kind of like disappointing
things that I have learned as I've gotten
to spend more and more time
with increasingly influential
people and kind of how
the world works is that there is no
plan and there is no group figuring out
everything and it's kind
of like up to all of us.
Everyone hopes like the reason conspiracy
theories are so appealing is that like
everybody wants there to be a conspiracy.
Like you want to think that like
someone has a plan, um, that, you know,
there's like,
there's all this stuff happening but
someone's got a centralized plant and it's
all gonna work out.
And like,
I think one of the sad realizations of
growing up is that there are no grownups,
um, no one has this master plan. And if,
if we don't participate,
the thing can just go off the rails.
What do you think are some of the most
effective ways for employees at a large
tech company like Google to get
involved in government and politics? Um,
everyone wants an answer other than this
one because it would be more convenient.
But I think one of the answers
is to just run for office.
We have this process,
we have this like system instead of
rules that we've all agreed to. Um,
and everyone wants some way to hack
around the edges of that rather than just
participate directly.
MMM.
That's okay.
There are good things to do.
But I think just taking the problem head
on is, uh, not enough people try that.
And
there's rumors going around that Mark
Zuckerberg is gonna run for office like
every other week.
And then there's also been rumors about
you running for governor and we've seen
a tech people run for office in the past.
Meg Whitman ran for governor of California
in 2010 but she lost by a significant
margin to Jerry Brown.
So my question is,
do you think that it's actually feasible
for someone in tech to run for office
and win or is there too much of this
perception of the tech industry as being
elitist such that people
will connect with voters?
I think there is,
I think at least people should try.
I think the tech industry is
the most hated in the bay area.
And if you go out throughout the
rest of the state or the country,
there's a lot of people who think
it's really cool. They aspire to it,
they want it, they want
to participate in it. Um,
and I think it is easy to get too negative
a view of how technology people are
perceived here. I Dunno if a tech
person can win the presidency.
I have a feeling we're going to find out.
Um,
but what I am confident
about is that tech,
not people from the technology industry
could start winning local school board
and city council and you know,
congressional seats.
That'd be a great thing to start with.
Is there any
person currently living that you
would want to run for president?
Who's your ideal candidate?
Okay.
I do. I can't answer that on the
fly. That's, I, I would like,
it's a good question to think about
when you said that. I was like, oh,
I should figure out who that person
is. Go try to convince them to run. Um,
but I don't have an answer like
ready to go all in my head. Okay.
Well with that, I'm going to open
up the floor for audience questions.
So if you have a question, feel free to
go to the mic in the back of the room.
We're also submit your
question to the Dory.
Go for it.
Hi. Um, you mentioned the anecdote
about your friend being unhappy and,
and Kim Kardashians and it reminded
me of a quote and it's set up.
Okay.
People aren't unhappy because
they want to be happy.
They're unhappy because they want
to be happier than other people.
And you mentioned that technology
may or may not be able to solve this.
So I like to hear some of your ideas or
success strategies on how to solve this
on a micro and macro level,
whether it be delete Twitter too.
That's a little thing to do. Um,
that's a good thing to do. I, uh,
yeah, I deleted all the social apps
from my phone. Um, and I, you know,
I can still like check them on
my computer when I want, but, uh,
I don't have that like constant urge to
like push button for dopamine hit here.
Um, and that's, that's been
really good. Um, you know,
I think after talking to a bunch of
these people about the things that make
people happy,
there's like the obvious stuff,
which is like spend time with loved ones,
um,
that everyone knows even if they don't do.
But there's a bunch of things that are
like very not or less obvious to me that
seemed to have huge measured effects.
Um,
like taking time to think about the
things that went well as opposed to things
you're upset about or like going for a
walk outside every day no matter what. Um,
and I think as we get sort of to
abundance and unlimited resources,
this is going to be a
more important topic. Um,
what I would encourage you to do is to,
uh,
just like start reading. There's a
lot of literature on the subject.
No one seems to care about
enough to spend time,
but I would say start reading it.
Um,
and hopefully I'll finish
my blog post on it soon.
Thank you.
Hey Sam, thanks for coming. Uh,
wanted to ask a question about the larger
landscape. As you see in general, uh,
heard a rumor that YC is
looking into a growth fund.
I think at Brooklyn Tech
crunch like a month ago,
like potentially raising
a billion dollar fund. Uh,
wanted to get your thoughts on growth
versus venture and how you see growth
evolving. Uh, for the bay area in general,
you see private companies staying
private longer and longer.
So, um, we already have a growth
fund. It's called a YC continuity. Um,
we raised the first one in 2015.
Um, it's about halfway invested.
Uh, and it, it basically
follows on in capitol,
in YC companies.
One of the things that I wanted to do
after I joined YC was start to fund hard
tech companies. Um, nuclear fusion,
synthetic biology, quantum computing,
self driving cars, long
list. Um, and one of the,
the, one of the good things
that I realized is that
nobody else was funding those
companies. And so we
could have our pick. Um,
one of the bad things that I realized is
nobody else was funding those companies.
Um, and so we could fund them all we
wanted and there was no follow on capital.
And I think,
so that was the action.
The genesis for our growth fund is that
there is this class of companies that I
think are really important and really
valuable and they weren't getting funded
since then. We've expanded it and
we fund lots of other companies. Um,
I will certainly say that,
um,
there is no shortage of growth capital
for software companies in Silicon Valley.
Like, you know, it may have gotten
harder to raise a seed or an a round.
It probably has somewhat, but
if you have things working, uh,
like when you want to go raise a,
B or c round and you have like
this beautiful exponential growth,
like you will not be able to keep up
with the number of terms sheets you're
getting.
That is the stage that I think just has
a huge amount of capital allocated to it.
As,
as companies are staying private longer
as public market investors have a harder
and harder time finding alpha.
Um,
they are more than willing
to do stuff like this. So,
uh, that part of the market,
um, is not suffering, at
least not yet. Thanks. Sure.
Let me do a question from the dory.
Uh,
we have a question about universal basic
income and how we've Google has been
supporting give directly to research
on UBI in Africa and you're a proponent
here in the u s so what
are your thoughts on how,
when and where the universal basic
income approach might be most effective?
Yeah. Um, I don't think universal basic
income is a solution to all problems.
Um,
I think in fact of the bigger problem
that we were talking about earlier of what
makes people happy and fulfilled and feel
needed and valued and have meaning in
their lives. Um, it is not
sufficient to solve that problem.
And I don't think it will replace like
the entire other social safety net.
Like the people who are like eliminate
everything else. You know, no healthcare,
no schools, no minimum wage. I'm put basic
income. I don't believe in that either.
But I do think that if
we do all of our jobs,
if we silicon valley do all of our jobs,
we will create more wealth than the
world has ever seen before and less jobs.
And in that world,
um,
I think there is a moral
obligation to eliminate poverty.
I think poverty is a
obviously very bad thing,
but it is worse even than
people realize. Um, if you,
if you look at the studies on the longterm
psychological damage that living in
Cotsen poverty does to people and how
it means that you never got a chance to
really invest in your own future because
you're always just trying to survive,
I think there's just a huge amount of
wasted potential. And so, you know,
there are a lot of arguments about ubi.
This was another thing,
like when we started this
a couple of years ago,
I did not predict at all that this was
going to ignite into this big national
debate. It was like, we're just
trying to hire a researcher, you know,
like maybe this is a good
idea, can we just do a project?
And it's just been like,
um,
so I don't think I quite understand why
it has become such a national issue so
quickly. But I do think
that a longer term, um,
if we have the ability
to eliminate poverty,
we will get a lot more out
of the world as a whole.
As he started the research
experiment in East Bay.
Have you noticed anything that maybe
you didn't expect or has it changed your
attitude towards it in any way?
You know, we're like seven or eight
months into a five year study, so not yet.
Okay.
Hi Sam. I'm thinking more in general a
founders, but this could be general too,
but what
advice do you frequently give,
but you find most people never
actually follow through on?
Uh, I mean, no one ever listens
to any advice, any sort. Um,
so all of it, uh, I think,
okay.
I think the thing that people,
well,
the piece of advice that people later
say, they wish they had listened to. Um,
is that it is very easy to get sucked
into a path in life and you know,
you can do things like say, oh, I want
to start a startup someday, or oh,
I want to be are, you
know, AI researcher Sunday,
but first I'm going to go do
this other job to like, you know,
make money and gain
experience and whatever.
And it's so easy to like get sucked into
a path where you spend your entire life
doing something that is not
really what you want to do.
MMM.
That's probably the piece of advice that
I have given people that they have most
often come to me like
five years later and said,
I really wish I had listened to that.
Thank you.
Sure.
I'm curious to hear your thoughts on
relative rates of progress in Ai between
China and everywhere else.
So you mentioned nobody has a plan,
but China has a plan for state
level centralized investment Nai,
whereas Elon Musk is calling for
regulation that would slow down. Yeah,
definitely everywhere else.
Uh, China does plan. That's
true. Um, they don't,
it doesn't always work. They don't always
have global coordination. Um, you know,
like right now we're in this kind of world
where it seems like you have like the
Internet in China, on the Internet
and the rest of the world. Um,
maybe they have a plan
for their piece of it. Um,
I don't honestly know how far along China
is with AI and I don't think anybody
else honestly really does either.
MMM.
I think it would be bad to get into
an arms race. We'll try and over Ai.
I ain't got something we
should try to avoid. Um,
and I think there is a real opportunity,
although
it might,
we may not have the leaders in place
to do it right now to make this a joint
kind of like worldwide project.
Um,
rather than another space
race or nuclear arms race.
Thanks.
Hi Sam. I was wondering if you could
expand a little bit on funding.
Hard tech cause they ain't,
is was a big problem with a
private capital allocation
and like $70 billion was
put into VC last year,
which is a drop in the bucket in
terms of worldwide investment.
So do you see like YC maybe raising in
$100 billion fund in the future? Namely,
how can we solve this?
I think capital is allocated really badly.
Um,
and unfortunately there are huge efforts.
Like if you have this
really valuable thing,
which is you get access to invest in
great startups and most of the world
doesn't,
um,
then there will obviously be a super
return there and you're going to work
really hard to protect
that. Um, and so I think,
um, I think expanding access
to invest in startups,
which is happening but slowly it's a
really good thing to do. And I think, um,
you know, like crowdfunding
equity crowdfunding, we're
still in the early days of,
but he's an important trend.
Uh,
and I think that will change the capital
allocation. I think you're seeing,
I think you're seeing startups in all
these different ways go to non traditional
funders. Um, and that's been really good.
We first saw that with consumer hardware.
We're now seeing that in a lot
of other places. Um, you know,
I think the other thing that's
happening finally is there's just,
and there's bad to this too,
but there's just a huge amount of more
capital coming in to fund early stage
private companies,
mid stage private companies.
And I expect that in a world
where interest rates stay
even close to as low as
they are. Um, we are in the very
early innings of that trend.
So I think capital
we'll get, you know, my,
my general model is that the world
is very complex financial system,
capital sloshes around looking
for the best return. Um,
there are periods where there's
a really outperforming return,
but then more capital gets allocated
there. And I think we're seeing that now.
But did you think that a nuclear fusion
company could raise $100 million in an
ICO or something like that?
Or maybe I wouldn't suggest
that they do an ICO. Um,
but I do think they can
raise $100 million, uh,
and I don't think they
could have three years ago.
And I think that's a really positive trend
for the world, that this stuff is now,
um,
at least somewhat possible.
Awesome. Thanks. Sure.
Another dory question,
what are the most common reasons that
qualified candidates get rejected from YC?
MMM,
yeah.
Well there is one particular
thing that is, uh,
that happens a lot with super talented
people from large tech companies.
So since I'm here I'll mention that one.
Um,
which is you are really great person,
really talented, really smart.
I'm really driven and you don't have an
a good idea or you don't have any idea
and so you make up a bad one. Um, and
there's this like myth about startups,
the idea doesn't matter at all. Um,
and I think that's just,
there's existential proof
that that's not true. Um,
and I think
there is,
there is this particular failure mode
of people from the big tech companies,
which is like, hey, I'm really
talented and well, I guess you are. Um,
so I'm going to like start a company
and I'll figure out what to do later.
And I think that isn't usually
what produces the great companies.
And so we have learned, um, that
it's much, much better if you're
otherwise a qualified candidate. Um,
to have a, have a good idea.
And I think that's the,
that would be the common failure
case for people coming out of Google.
Hmm.
Hey Sam. Hey. So, um, what are
your thoughts about, you know,
where you're going to go or what you're
going to do with your life after YC or
does that come across? Are you going
to take a political office series?
You know, I don't even like know what
I'm going to do in three weeks. Um,
I uh,
I plan to run YC for a really long time.
Um, I, I do plan to get continually
more involved with politics,
but I'd like to support others.
Um, not run for office myself,
at least not anytime soon. Um, you know,
like I am a big believer in
do the things that you like,
think about in the shower in the morning
when you can think about anything you
want and you're kind of mind is just off.
And the things that
keep coming back to her,
like how can I make YC like
a hundred times bigger?
How can I make sure that their
rival of the AI goes well? Um,
and in the short term,
how can I help our political
system from going off the rails so,
or any more off the rails not
already has. Um, so, you know,
I kind of plan to keep working on
those things for hopefully, you know,
a really long time.
Thanks.
Hi. Thank you for being here. I
have a question about the general,
um,
eh way silicon valley works because it
seems like it's a system which in which
you have like the most talented mines.
Dylan would maybe not the
most important teachers.
Like you have the sharpest mind
walking on social apps or mobile apps,
but we still don't have a cure for
cancer or we still don't have a,
another way of like having energy or like
really important stuff that the world
should handle. Em. So my question
is, do you agree with that?
What is your perspective on that and
how do you think maybe this can be
addressed?
Okay.
I don't agree with that. I think, um,
I used to be my job as a capital allocator
and now I view my job as a cowlick
allocator.
So most of my day is like spent meeting
with really smart people and trying to
convince them to work on
important problems. And you know,
I think,
okay,
in 2007 what everyone said is the best
minds of our generation used to build
spaceships and now they're like
moving numbers around a Wall Street.
And in 2017 what people say is the best
minds of our generation and used to
build space ships and now they get
me to click on ads and you know,
there's always some truth then there's
always someone to pick on there. Um,
but like I think open AI has some
of the smartest minds in our world.
If our generation working on having
an AI go, well, I think helium,
which is that fusion company,
I mentioned some of the smartest minds
of our generation working on nuclear
fusion. Um, why? See, I
think last time I counted,
it's funded eight companies
working on a cure for cancer.
Incredibly talented people are
cures for cancer cancers. Um,
I think you can always say there's all
these people like working on bad stuff or
stuff. It doesn't matter. But, you know,
I think Google is still like a
really great thing for the world. Uh,
this is why we're here. Yeah.
And I think it does matter.
I think it's always easy
to pick on people and say,
you're not working on a cure for cancer.
You know, you're wasting your time,
but you're making this thing better that
people use every day and their lives
would be a lot worse if it went away
and you're making it better every day.
And I think it's, it's, it's really
easy to pick on people, um, and say,
you know,
that person's not spending her time right.
And I think it always says more about
the person that says that then the person
they're pointing to. And if you're
doing something useful for the world,
if you're doing something you enjoy,
if you're sort of like,
even if you're making a small impact,
but on a product that a lot of
people really use and love, um,
I think that's really valuable.
And I think the people who
say this generally have a
lot of insecurity about how
they're spending their time.
So you don't think like silicon valley
is like avoiding the tough problems.
I invite you to like,
come sit in my office for a day and like
listen to the people coming through and
what they're working on. A, I really don't
think that, no. Okay, cool. Thank you.
Hey, Sam. Uh, seeing that you're
largely influential public figure, um,
could you speak to the privileges
that might've led to that, um,
and helped you with your success and,
um,
how you may be a good or bad ally.
And then also seeing that a lot of our
consumer products are largely bias,
um, specifically to the
people who create them,
which was largely silicone
valley engineers like myself
and others in this room.
Uh, how do you keep your ideas
and thoughts diverse and, um,
addressing intersectional needs?
Yeah, great question. Um,
I basically had like nearly
all of the possible privileges.
I had wonderful loving parents. Um, I
grew up in a safe house. I'm a white guy.
Um,
we had enough money that I was able to
pursue the things that I was interested
in and go to a great college.
Um, and it's never lost on me.
How if I had been born
a mile in a different place to a different
family, um, different skin color,
different gender,
I wouldn't be where I am now.
I view that as an obligation to try to
make the world more just going forward.
Um, I think anyone who is really
successful and doesn't like,
I think anyone should try to do the
best they can with whatever hand they're
dealt. But if you're dealt, you know,
like four aces then and you win,
then I think you have an extra obligation
to try to sort of make the world a
little better.
So I try to be really thankful of what
everyone's done that has allowed me to do
this.
Um,
I also try to figure out
how to pay that forward. Um,
and I think,
I think anyone who is really successful
or almost anyone who is really
successful has, um, like
privilege luck's going hard work.
And I think people who try to say it's
just one or just the other all tend to be
wrong.
Um,
so I'm thankful for that and
I try to pay that forward. Um,
I, in terms of biases
in the product, I think,
uh, this is one of the reasons that
diverse teams are most important.
The moral question aside, uh,
that consumer products, the teams,
the companies that I think have done the
best job addressing this head on have
had a very diverse set of
voices around the table.
And I think that is always the strategy
I recommend cause that's the only one
I've seen consistently work. Cool.
Thank you. Sure. We're on time now,
but if you can do these last
three questions quickly,
we can get through them.
Sure. Thank you for coming. Sam. Uh,
my question is on machine learning and
artificial intelligence companies. Uh,
it seems to me that the scarce or valuable
thing is data in those areas and less
so the algorithm because
it mostly open source.
So I was wondering how you think about
that when getting pitches from company,
a company. I used to believe that I now
believe that it's going to be compute,
not data. I think data is important but
there will be a lot of it available.
Uh, and just my own
experience with open AI, um,
to really be at the forefront here you
just need massive amounts of compute.
And so I used to ask companies like how
they're going to get a lot of data and I
ask them how they're going to go out
of compute. It's okay. Thank you. Sure.
Hey Sam, thanks for coming. Um, I know
you were talking about like, you know,
people are already becoming
unhappier and the world food problem,
all this kind of things that
are kind of like quantifiable,
like physical needs of people.
Have you ever had companies that come
to you kind of like try to solve the
spiritual needs of people because
we can identify the physical needs,
but what about like spiritual needs
or research or companies? We have had
a few, um, none of them have really
worked yet. Uh, but you know,
one that like stuck out of memory was
a company came to us and said like,
churches, like, you know,
organized religion had this really
important effect that was totally separate
from the religion itself,
which was this,
this tight knit community and how do you
build that in a world where most people
are declining, number of people believe
in religion and go to church. Um,
and so I think there are people
thinking about things like that,
which are sort of these
non obvious attacks on the
problem that are interesting,
but none that I could yet 0.2 is, here's
this thing that's really worked well.
He say, I'm a, so you partnered
with the ACL Aclu earlier this year,
which you got mixed reactions to you.
I'm wondering what you've learned
from that whole experience, uh,
what successes you've had
and what partnerships who
are looking forward to with
other nonprofits in the future?
I, I've been, I was really excited
about how that went. That was a,
we had never done anything
like that before. Um,
we often try new things usually
don't work. Sometimes they do.
That's when we would do again. Um,
we would do something more like that.
I think there are these really important
organizations in the world that can use
our help to build better technology teams.
Um,
and that was an experiment that went well
and, but we'd love to try it again. Um,
one of our software engineers,
Cajun went there for,
I think she went for
like eight weeks almost.
The whole program sat in
their office has helped them.
We got a call from him later
about how well it went,
been able to help them put it, you know,
expand and supplement their team. Um,
and that, you know, I think that's
something we'd like to try again.
And one last question
because this has gotten,
so Elon Musk recently call the floor
preemptive AI regulation at the National
Governors Association. As a chair
of open AI and friend of mosques,
what is your opinion on this issue and
what specific actions can we take to
minimize future risk?
The specific thing I would support
today is just, um, insight. Like,
I think the government should understand
where the edge of capabilities are and
how it's evolving. Um,
because I think no one,
certainly not the government knows what
the regulation for AI should look like
today, but I'd be in favor of starting
that education process. Awesome. So yeah,
that was our last question.
Thank you all everyone.
[inaudible].